but my big discovery and why i really
started loading up on
ethereum was another chart
which was a
understanding that metcalfe's law
was the primary driver of all crypto
markets and in fact
almost all of the tech stocks that we've
known today
and once you realize that these are
basically networks and once you realize
that crypto
are networks where you actually own the
network so facebook is a great network
stock and it works perfectly on a log
chart and it's an exponential does all
the things as you imagine you can value
it in metcalf's law terms but the
fundamental difference is shareholders
and network users are not aligned the
shareholders make the money the network
users get the utility
along comes crypto you
marry
the the network
user with the owner okay now you've got
networker pet effects upon network
effects this is like behavioral
economics
right manifest religion meets michael's
law right it's like
now i'm trying about the thing
it's religion meets capitalism it's
basically what it is right so that is
incredibly powerful
[Music]
so for those who don't know you
basically you were at goldman you
started your own hedge fund and then it
seemed like you you retired correct you
retired pretty young you retired at 36.
but i mean now you're you have a company
now so you're not you know fully retired
and kicked back but no i've got four
jobs i'm doing right now so
right but you did have a break in
between correct so like i think it was
2004 when you when you sort of retired
from the hedge fund and it was like 2014
or something when you launched you know
real vision so what was going on in
between were you doing nothing or you
were doing other projects
i was writing global macro investor but
that is a monthly publication so i don't
know why all of you guys do weekly
newsletters or daily newsletters that's
hard work so i yeah i wrote monthly it's
big it's like well it starts off at
about 35 pages a month and then
due to uh inflation it gets to
um about 130 pages a month now but i
write it in a weekend so wow in i was
living in spain wrote one weekend a
month sure i need to monitor markets and
talk to people but
it was a part-time job um so really what
i've done is kind of opted out of the
rat race moved to the mediterranean
coast of spain i was growing fruit and
vegetables in my garden and almonds and
olives and all of that stuff living the
beach life in spain um in the middle of
a on the side of a mountain in the
middle of national park having a great
life
in the end you might start missing
intellectual capital
p the people around you because most of
the people most of the year round in a
beach town in spain work in a bar
restaurant or they um
or they're in real estate
which is fine but you feel very isolated
when your world is global macro
totally so so describe the moment
because i think a lot of people listen
to this so just so i don't know how much
you know about the podcast but
basically
the podcast is usually me and sam who
he's not here because he's traveling
he's actually in portugal right now
um we just sort of usually spit we're
both founders both recently sold our
companies in the last two years we
started the podcast after we sold
because that's when you have a bunch of
time on your hands and um and it's
usually just spitballing different kind
of like business opportunities market
opportunities and so just stuff that we
see that we think could work or is
interesting but we're not gonna go do it
ourselves so this became our outlet to
do that and um and so you get like we
have like i don't know like over a
million downloads a month and those
people what the people who listen what
they're doing is
um
they typically are either like they want
to start a business but they don't they
have like a good paying job they're
looking at making the leap or they have
their own business and this is like
they're doing this while they're you
know doing their chores and it's like i
get to hang out with my buddies who are
shooting the [__] about business because
like you know we talk about stuff that
they want to talk about they just don't
maybe have the friends around them that
want to talk nerd out about business all
the time and so we kind of had that same
uh thing where you needed that
intellectual sparring to uh to feel good
but the thing you mentioned which was
like you know you sort of won one game
you're doing well in one game but you
decided to exit the rat race
what was that what did you have like a
kind of come to jesus moment what did
you have like was that a long time
coming how did that happen
my meta narrative is the game is life
itself
the game is not money the game is
quality of life and how you live it so
that was always my objective so when i
was
on the tube in london at 5 15 in the
morning to get my get to my desk at
goldman before six
the reason i did it
is because i knew that the next thing i
wanted to do was go and live in the
mediterranean
and wanted to have that quality of life
you know for me
a lot of people think of money as the
primary objective i actually like houses
as you can tell from the house behind me
right because this is where i live this
is the quality of life this is my bank
this is everything
um and so i like where i live and how i
live that's why i live in the cayman
islands that's why i lived in spain
they're beautiful places
and i live a quality of life so that has
always been my journey
but what i want to do is i always take
steps towards the endgame i kind of live
in the future always in everything that
i do
so i always have a vision of my future
self
or whether that's future state of
financial markets where i think it's
going whatever it may be i'm always well
ahead
and so i then can look it's much easier
to live in the future and look back and
say how do i get here
then stand here today and go i want to
go forward it's kind of weird it's a
psychology thing and so
i had realized that the mediterranean
was
this life and i was my ex-girlfriend
when i was at university
um her mother lived in majorca in spain
and i was there in mallorca one point
and we were on this small beach eating
grilled sardines that was this perfect
mediterranean scene right grill sardines
somebody's making a big oil drum on the
beach
you've got a cold beer some grilled
sardines and on this little mini
peninsula there's a bunch of pine trees
and palm trees and there's this long
table of like 30 people 25 people
of different age groups parents kids
grandparents eating paella the spanish
national dish
on this sunday drinking wine laughing
i'm like that is quality of life
and so i kept that in my mind
and so i kind of facilitated it to
happen that i would move to spain
right
um and i did it in steps as well so i
did it in the step that
i was speaking to my father i was having
dinner with him
and he's like and i i was just chatting
a few glasses of wine i was like you
know i'd love to buy a house in spain at
some point
and he said you know i've got a friend
selling a house in spain a random thing
so i said sure well let me know
so he sent he he this is in the day of
faxes this is like
1998 or something he sends me a fax
of this six-bedroom house on a hillside
in spain
i'm not that's great dad how the hell am
i supposed to afford it
he's like i was 30 years old i was
working at goldman he's like well i
don't know how much it is
so he came back and said it was 150 000
pounds which at the time was like 250
000 us 200 000 us
and i just had a bonus and i thought
well i can actually buy that in cash and
i did right
and it was game changing i had a
mortgage in london and everything else
was game-changing because now i'd won
the entire game i've got a six bedroom
house on a hillside in spain overlooking
orange groves 10 minutes to the beach
and i could lose my job
i could still have anything
and i could work in a bar and i could
live there
i'm done right my gaming life was one so
that that was the marker stone to allow
me to take more risk to do the next
thing and so that's how i've always done
these things
and how do you get that vision so i'm
the same way but what i've noticed about
myself is like
every
i call them like these chapters so it's
like every sort of like five years is
like a new chapter and what i've noticed
if i go look back at the kind of last
three chapters so i'm i'm 30
about to be 34 so basically you know
three chapters i i've done three
chapters now and each time it was sort
of this like fortuitous bounce where i
get in touch with somebody and they show
me a glimpse into this lifestyle or this
kind of like mode that they're in
and then i just can't unsee it i'm like
why the hell am i not doing that right
it's your version of seeing people
eating paella drinking wine at a 30
table just enjoying life on the by the
water and you're like
that's the glance that that's the
glimpse i needed to do it so is that how
you also got your vision for the next
for the next kind of like chapter yeah
so the next thing was not so i'd been in
spain and i realized the thing i was
missing was intellectual capital even
though my clients were the world's most
famous hedge fund managers you know all
of these super smart guys but they
weren't around me they're all around the
world
and
it was not as easy to get in touch
twitter wasn't really around you know
there was less ways to be social online
podcast didn't really exist right so
and then i think i probably discovered
tim ferriss
and another friend of mine mark hart had
gone down this journey of looking at
silicon valley and entrepreneurship
and that was the thing that i thought
okay this is the next thing for me how
can i how can i take the entrepreneurial
journey outside of you know setting up
my own research business which was a
one-man band essentially
i wanted to take that entrepreneur's
journey and push myself i wanted to see
what i was capable of
um so that was the next that was the
next thing and give people a sense so
you're at goldman that's a good job uh
what are you making back then uh you
know basically like what what was your
kind of like
because i think for a lot of people
they're like okay some people feel
trapped when they're when they're making
a high salary at a nice company they
feel trapped they don't they don't take
those leaps and other people they'll
look at this and say well it's easy for
you you probably are making a bunch of
money at the time uh you know so yeah
you could take these leaps of faith
because you had kind of a safety net so
but wait why in the clock back we were
talking almost 20 years ago or something
like that um
you know how are you doing financially
then versus you know at those two steps
kind of research
i've been really lucky you know i worked
in the banking industry
selling
derivatives to hedge funds right so
these are the mega trend of finance the
mega trend of derivative and the mega
trend of hedge funds so i you know i was
doing pretty well you know at 30 years
old i was only earning more than a
million dollars a year
um so
but you managed to walk away from that
which is pretty impressive yeah and i
first went to a hedge fund don't forget
so i left goldman went to hedge fund so
i took a risk but
i used to argue with my boss every time
he used to give me share options
and uh restricted stock i'm like thank
you it's worthless i'd rather have cash
because how dare you you should be proud
to have equity in goldman and that's why
we can give you so much more
compensation i said it's worthless
he said why do you say that because it's
not money i can spend
so he got really pissed off with me and
then when i finally quit to go to
my biggest customer and the biggest
customer of goldman's equity derivative
equity desk
um entire equity floor in europe uh glg
partners
he then called me into his office and
goes well you were dead right
it was worthless
he said
so i lost all um i managed to cash in
some of it but i lost
millions of dollars to make that move
but i wanted to make that move because i
wanted to see whether i could if i could
run money myself and be a macro investor
because it was another chapter that i
wanted to pursue for my own goals
and then
let's kind of fast forward till today so
you came on my radar
i think i had seen real vision a few
times but i hadn't i'm not from the
finance world from the silicon valley
tech world and you know so we all kind
of have our like media sources that we
learn from based on whatever industry
you care about right
and so i had seen it but i hadn't really
paid too much attention uh but i saw you
start talking about crypto and this was
um you i didn't realize that you had
actually started talking about crypto
back in i don't know 2013 2014 and i
went back and i read your old kind of
like memos and stuff that you know put
up screenshots about
so you know like you said ahead of the
curve
you have the receipts to prove it um
but i think it was 2019 or 2020 where
you started becoming very vocal and then
you made the big splash where you were
like i've moved
some ridiculous part of your liquid net
worth i think it was i think you might
have said fifty percent at one point i
thought you third you say ninety percent
into crypto yeah
100 into crypto and um so that caught my
attention and the attention of a bunch
of other people and so you know i know
you've talked about this before but
there's a new audience so give give kind
of the origin story of how the mind
virus of crypto kind of like what were
the steps where you went from like
curious to convinced what what was that
journey like for you where you put in
percent or hundred percent because my
job is to live in the future so i had
got i had lived through the financial
crisis and predicted it
i had also lived through the european
and had been in europe and had to buy a
generator and food
and get cash out of the bank and keep it
at home
right that's how close we were in spain
to losing our entire banking system
and as a macro guy i knew the issue was
leverage
and leverage had meant that we had a
unique problem which was
there's a layer of collateral
and all of this debt is against the
collateral
and usually you've got like 30 claims on
the same piece of collateral in fact the
average u.s treasury has 32 claims on it
or it did then may have more now
so therefore who owns what in an
unraveling
you know who's going to get screwed
and the
the leverage was uh you're talking about
government or corporate or where where
did you see this stock pile of funds
i look at total leverage financial
system leverage government leverage
um household leverage and private sector
leverage
right so we're at 480 percent of gdp now
whatever the stupid number is right it's
ridiculous but the problem is is that's
a lot of claims on the collateral
so because not everything is collateral
in the system only something's used as
collateral anyway so when lehman went
bust right everyone's scrambling to find
who owns what and you know that happens
all the time
so i started trying to start the world's
safest bank with a bunch of family
offices
um i thought you know we could stay a
bank that doesn't use leverage so then
people can put assets there their
savings there and realized they're safe
because it wasn't safe people in cyprus
had all of their money taken out by the
government
so i'm like okay i need to do something
about this and i can do something about
it so i started that journey and a
friend of mine called emil woods who was
a subscriber to global macro investor um
who was running a hedge fund at the time
an ex-goldman guy he said you need to
look at bitcoin
and i read a bit about bitcoin it's
probably 2012
and i
wrote the first macro
piece on bitcoin which is i think the
thing you referred to yeah which is
2013. it's like i saw it and thought
okay so we've got two things here one is
this
asset bitcoin
and that's a scarce asset in the digital
world so that's probably interesting and
secondly we've got blockchain which is a
recorded ownership of everything okay
well that solves the entire financial
system and this could be something
useful for the financial system in
itself as a new version of gold so i
backed out that the fair value of
bitcoin with gold at 1300 using the kind
of supply you know stock to flow ratio
done badly you know i'm no
you know statistician or
econometrics expert but i kind of backed
it out so it's probably worth a million
bucks
and then how i like to look at things is
okay
what's the price now 200
let's assume probably rightly that raoul
is a total idiot so let's assume he's
wrong by 90
so it's worth a hundred thousand dollars
and it's at 200 that is the best single
bet i've ever seen in my entire life so
i bought it and i wrote about it and i
held it all the way through till and
when you say you bought it that's like a
like the first time i bought bitcoin i
bought like i don't know a thousand
dollars a bitcoin right so i bought it
means what like you bought a tiny bit
you bought a medium amount or you went
like you put a significant stake for
yourself into it
a decent a decent enough amount
um and i sold it after a 10x
so i'd done well from it
sadly i got divorced in the process so i
halved that so there was my tax that i
don't pay and i came in
i chose a voluntary 50 tax um
so you know it wasn't a life-changing
bet but it was a it was a good bet now
had i held it on to 20 000 when it
peaked yeah it would have been
life-changing so okay so i've been in it
i got out i was nervous about all of
these four king wars and everything
going on and i don't understand this
let's wait and see and then
i had talked about it
a lot analyzed it been involved in it
but hadn't been investing it again until
2019 started sticking my toes in again
because the market had been selling off
i was starting to get comfortable that
yes that we got a recession coming this
is going to be a useful tool
and then 2020 comes along um and i was
already positioned for a recession
but you know this opportunity was like
okay if the central banks are going to
print like crazy then that's the
opportunity so i bought a lot of bitcoin
at that point i was long bonds
gold
dollars
bitcoin
and then over time i started charting
bitcoin versus other assets
and i realized its dominance in
performance was so extreme that it made
no sense to own other assets even with
the fact that bitcoin can be very
volatile and have periods like now or
it's down 50
it's like it makes no sense to own
anything else now i probably will take
other bets here and there
but i think my core strategic so i was
bitcoin first then i started doing the
work i was on twitter a lot um
and
people if i were to ask anything about
ethereum people would pile on to me that
makes me want to know more so i start
digging in has the opposite reaction
i knew what about ethereum and you know
but i started properly digging in and i
thought you know this is really bloody
interesting the chart looks incredible
the chop versus bitcoin looks incredible
um this makes sense to me
so um i started
switching
um into ethereum
and when you say the chart looks
incredible so tell me what that means so
i've uh like i said come from the tech
world we look at charts all the time but
they're always like
users revenue uh things that sort of
like are not uh based on specular you
know any kind of like uh speculation or
human whims human emotion exactly um so
you know charts don't lie or you know
they they do if you
but unless unless you know what you're
looking at so
when you talk about charts i've seen you
know i see people like do this all the
time on twitter where they're like you
know it's voodoo magic they see a chart
then they draw this like crazy shape oh
clearly this is doing a reverse cyclone
pattern and it's going to go all the way
up and so are you one of those guys
where you actually do the technical
analysis and you say no the price chart
is what i'm looking at or were you
looking at other charts
um both so um and i'll come on to that
so price chart i think is the best guide
of
what the asset is doing what its trend
is how it how people are perceiving it
and where it is versus what you might
perceive as fair value so okay you know
you you notice certain characteristics
like crypto tends to be exponential in
price so you put on the logarithmic
chart it starts to make sense you know
you look at things like copper and
lumber they tend to be mean reverting
assets because you they get met by
excess supply with high prices lead to
excess supply so right now with oil at
100 bucks everybody wants to make as
much oil as possible so the price comes
down over time it doesn't happen with
crypto because you can't right so you
need to understand the structure of
markets where the sentiment is is it
overly bearish like a day like today it
got overly bearish and so suddenly you
start to see a reversal so these kind of
things are interesting but my big
discovery and why i really started
loading up on
ethereum was another chart
which was a understanding that
metcalfe's law
was the primary driver
of all crypto markets and in fact almost
all of the tech stocks that we've known
today
and once you realize that these are
basically networks and once you realize
that crypto
are networks where you actually own the
network so facebook is a great network
stock and it works perfectly on a log
chart and it's an exponential does all
the things as you imagine you can value
it in metcalf's law terms but the
fundamental difference is shareholders
and network users are not aligned the
shareholders make the money the network
users get the utility
along comes crypto you
marry
the the network
user with the owner okay now you've got
network of effects upon network effects
this is like behavioral economics
right manufacturing religion meets matt
mccaff's law right it's like
it's religion meets capitalism it's
basically what it is right so that is
incredibly powerful
so i start looking at the fact that
bitcoin and ethereum charts just at
different points when they at the same
point in adoptions like were remarkably
similar and then it dawned on me as
they're all the bloody same thing
they're all about adoption
so then so so if you look at it and if
you're honest with yourself
ethereum if you think about metcalfe's
law it's about the number of
users
and then the kind of connections between
the users and the applications built to
create those connections
well bitcoin's kind of a one-sided one
which is a bunch of people own it as a
store of value like gold nothing wrong
with that
but there's not many applications built
in when you look at ethereum it's like
holy [__]
i mean this is like the internet
right that moment is like okay this is
far superior a bet
um
and so that's why i took that bet and
then i eventually shifted
majority into ethereum and then took
other bets in the space to express macro
views
yeah uh it's funny i i have uh one tenth
of the intelligence of you but i did the
exact same pattern so you know i heard
about it in 2013 bought a little bit
dabbled sold during when you know i when
i went to a wedding and my aunt was
telling me about how great bitcoin
ethereum was i was like oh it's probably
a bubble 2017 2018. sold for a nice
profit was patting myself on the back uh
you know in retrospect worst trade i
ever made should have just held
everything um you know bought started
buying back in
uh in 20
20 uh 2019 or 2020 i kind of announced
that i've uh i had moved 25 of all my
liquid net worth into the thing but that
was right before you know another
another run-up and so that became
quickly 50-60
and um and you know piers and some
people are telling you you're crazy i'm
sure you had the same and same thing you
know why are you betting on this are you
just kind of speculating and i said no
like basically i spent my whole career
studying the power of network effects
right i'm trying to build marketplaces
and social networks in silicon valley
because i know that a network effect is
the most powerful force imaginable and
uh and then i see this chart this
adoption chart of this new money network
it's like well if this if the if the
social network was worth x and the
information network was worthwhile
and then the you know the merchant
network which is like you know basically
amazon um it was worth you know z then
then this thing is going to be the money
network's going to be worth a lot i can
tell you that and so i was i didn't know
much more than that but i just knew
if you can bet early in a network effect
that's still going through it's kind of
like
you know adoption curve um
you know you'll do pretty well and so
that was kind of my my my bet um coming
from a comp you know sort of a different
different take but ended up at sort of
the same conclusion and i remember being
impressed that you were talking about
network effects because i didn't really
see a lot of people in kind of
traditional finance talking about that
at all and i was like they're missing
the point you know really one of the
first people to really start saying
unless you understand network effects
you understand what this is at all
because everyone's not defined on weird
things because people people listening
maybe don't know network connect so so
to define it network effects just
describes this phenomenon where uh let's
just take you know a language if i'm the
only person who speaks english english
is not very useful same thing with a
telephone system if i'm the only person
with a telephone it's not that useful
but now another person gets a telephone
or learns english well english just got
more valuable and then the more people
that learn english the more valuable
english is as a language and so it's
describes a phenomenon that every
participant that joins the network makes
the whole network more valuable so it's
like the opposite of like a popular
nightclub where everybody who joins
makes the thing sort of you know
diminishes the popularity over time
network effects typically describe that
and they it gets more valuable at it
square basically as an exponential not
linear
and then if you think about it in other
terms is let's say let's say let's look
at web 3 as a network and a network of
engineers engineering talent right this
is where it gets really interesting why
is it exponential
it's because there are parts
when everybody's trying to hire web 3
talent right we are every single person
i know is right
and the actual pool of people who are
capable of doing it is probably like a
thousand right and there are so
multi-millionaires who don't want jobs
that's the point is their
salaries and the demand for them
is exponential the demand for the
network of those guys becomes
exponential over time there'll be
millions of trained people and it
becomes the network effects the overall
space is very valuable
but the opportunity that ramp that's the
single most important interesting part
of network effects
right and the fact that you can own
a share of the network
so even when the network flattens out
and is now worth i think 200 trillion
dollars for the digital asset space it's
currently 2 trillion
that's 100x in market cap
that's huge we've never had anything
like this before
right like when the when the first when
the information network was getting
built out which is just the internet and
it was pretty clear like slowly but
surely people were adopting they were
getting online and then stuff was
getting built stuff to do and then
everybody who was online made made being
online better because you could
communicate with them or they might
write a blog or whatever the whole
internet was getting better the more
people that joined right that was a
network effect but you couldn't invest
in the internet like you couldn't just
invest in generically the internet and
so you had to pick you know certain
platforms and even then how how do you
become an let's say you believed in
amazon or ebay or whatever
you're only getting a slice of the total
internet and even then they don't want
you know the average person could not
invest
and that to me it feels like nfts right
now
we want to all get involved in nfts you
have no idea what's going to win
i mean i mean you don't have the ability
to go on every discord so it's bandwidth
constrained we all are in this space
we know it's huge we all know it's huge
we also know it's a bubble we also know
tons of this is going to zero
um that's fit
what's interesting about you only gives
you that gives you the uh action of nft
the kind of you know that that kind of
makes sense like owning oracle did a
pretty good job of capturing the
internet
right
and so you've been now kind of following
this and so
what what what is the viewpoint you had
about crypto that you've
changed your mind on or you've what you
believe before now you realize it's sort
of wrong and you think about it a
different way is there any has it been
anything is this kind of you know it's
kind of like this rapidly evolving thing
you're sort of like defogging this like
brand new world you know so you know
maybe some mental picture some mental
framework you had before
hasn't really held up and maybe
something different has happened can you
think of an example of that
well my views on bitcoin changed um
significantly i don't think
no less of it as an asset but i thought
about it in network terms and the
community and i thought the community is
not attracting new people and the job of
a network is to attract new participants
and if the network was actively
rejecting people i thought it's going to
underperform um which was surprising to
me because i was very bullish on bitcoin
first because i thought look it's going
to have a larger place and what's
happened is almost immediately
and it made me change my mind
is the institution started going well i
actually don't like this space
and they started buying eth
and that was so that's that's new i
haven't really heard that so tell me
about because you're connected to all
these folks right like you know
hedge fund guys cios whatever you know a
bunch of different people in that world
they don't want to own an asset where
everyone's shouting have fun stay poor
at each other and putting laser eyes
right makes them look [__] stupid
and irresponsible with their money well
eth feels like it's a technology play
yes it's amusing because everyone's
saying gm to each other and all of this
stuff but it's not at war
while bitcoin was at war with every
other network because you know that's
what networks do you know religions go
to war with each other for the same
reason right they're exactly the same
principles
um
so you know it's the same reason russia
and nato it's they're all the same
they're all networks fighting each other
for the robustness of their own network
i get it so that
that that whole process of seeing
institutions getting turned off by it
was a was a big deal to me i just
thought yeah i don't like this either so
that was one thing
um
i'm trying to think
well
you've seen a lot of news about
institutions buying bitcoin whether it's
tesla or microstrategy or square or you
know some like you know a random
insurance company buys 100 million
dollars worth of bitcoin so we've kind
of heard those we hear less of that with
eth is it just going on under the radar
is it coming what's your sense of that
because i haven't i'm in this space i
haven't heard a ton
it's happening
um below the radar because people keep
coming to me saying when's this wall of
money i'm like it doesn't come as a
tidal wave
it comes as a flow
right you don't see it until you look
back and go wow
so i mean i literally every other day
i'm speaking to the world's largest
financial institutions who put me in
front of their investment committees and
taught them through crypto and how to
invest and the narrative change really
surprised me it was always bitcoin you
know can we put bitcoin on our balance
sheet how should we invest in bitcoin
what's the diversification move very
quick to
look ethereum feels like it's a
technology play that makes sense with
the applications we can't we're
interested in d5 etcetera then it very
quickly became
oh [__] how do we get involved in web3
um so it moved very fast which is why in
the end vc got most of the money
um because they saw the broader
opportunity they all came through the
the 2020 lens of bitcoin is the asset
and you know the michael saylor route
and even me you know in the earlier part
of 2020 a lot of people came in that and
then like all of us they kind of go oh
wow okay this is much bigger so you know
i've started a fund of hedge funds um
which is
investing in crypto hedge funds
to allow institutions another way into
the market because they don't really
want to buy just eth or bitcoin they
want exposure to this two trillion
dollar asset class is going to go to 200
trillion over the next
10 12 15 years whatever the number is so
hedge funds are pretty good for that
because their job is to manage the
exposure and and to capture the
to capture this big move so you know
that's another way that it's coming in
that people don't see
um you know people it's not all about
the bitcoin etf i don't think that's
going to move the needle as much it'll
be positive
only in a positive market
yeah yeah the the way you describe it's
like it's not one giant wall of money
and like most things it's not you know a
single moment in time or it just goes
from from not here to here it's like a
it's more like a cascade of dominoes and
every day you hear something it's a
that's another domino that's tipping the
next domino
each one influences the next one and
then you sort of once you tip it off it
which has already happened it just takes
a matter of time until the whole domino
set runs through and it's all it's all
yeah and i i'm seeing institutions using
this weakness
and not being frightened by it so that
look this is fantastic opportunity i
need to use this i get it the volatile
space they they understand the people
who are trying to put capital work
understand
but once the price starts going up again
then you'll see the stampede
um right you know you know if bitcoins
at
sixty five thousand or seventy thousand
um
then people say okay we've had a
year-long correction
it's now going up next phase is going to
go to 106
right and they'll be in and they'll be
in and they'll be a mad panic because
they've all been doing the work over the
last year and a half so they'll be like
we've got to get in now got to get in
there because if they don't they miss
the out performance of their peers
who've got it
and what do you do with your east do you
uh like let put it into defy or you're
earning interest or your yields for you
you put it in a you block it away you
don't touch it
do you remember that story of the house
in spain once you win something
you don't let somebody else take it away
from you
it's as simple as that because if i was
staking
i get what five percent yield or if i'm
really clever and i
mess around in deep defy i'm getting
like a 15 yield
and then i get rugged
or something goes wrong or it's on an
exchange gets hacked i just that's not
the risk i want to take
it's not worth it if my expected future
return is
you know 10x
why take why get a 5 percent yield it's
nonsensical
so i just don't do it why yeah exactly
basically why take a even if it's a
small chance of multiplying the whole
thing by zero uh you know that's that's
not really the bet to make what i do is
i take a very small percentage and i say
this is my learning budget like because
i you know basically if i had done that
with bitcoin i would have just sort of
sat on my bitcoin never touched anything
else and i said well no actually it was
quite useful to start playing in
ethereum fairly early on and similarly
now playing in d5 or nfts you take a
learning budget and you say look this
isn't the principle this isn't the one
that's going to make all the money um
but this is also where i get to you know
continue to play the game and understand
how this whole thing unfolds
yeah and i've
i've never been interested in yield even
in financial markets all the old stuff
is boring to me i'm i'm a
i'm a guy who likes the capital game
room
yeah um and different people right
there's a whole bunch of people who love
yield it's called carry in financial
markets they want to get carrie
and others want to go for performance
and they're two different equations and
the carry guys do really really well
until they blow up
and the the guys like me tend to do
mediocre mediocre and then make huge
things they're just different ways of
skinning the cat
right so i spent my time because we
don't have enough
mental ability to focus on all the
things in the space so i started going
down a different rabbit hole i saw nfts
i understood it mainly
not all of it i understood that you know
that the
the macro view of what these things are
and how big this is
i wasn't really that interested in these
communities
give the uh here's my understanding of
nfts because i think like you know
the third most googled question is like
what is an nft so so you know even
people who
like hear about it maybe even own a
couple but they don't have a great frame
um and i think you're very good at
framing things and so give us your
current frame of nfts
so
ethereum
introduced a piece of magic
in a smart contract
a smart contract
attached to a blockchain
means that any contract in existence can
now be attached to a blockchain
and smart contracts allowed an algorithm
or a calculation to be made
automatically and verified on the chain
so that could be your insurance contract
for your house
it could be any of the contracts i mean
if you look around you almost everything
that we have in life is a contract
whether it's a spoken contract written
me appearing on this together with you
is a form of contract right so all of
these things are contractual
relationships that are everywhere what
this was saying is we can record all of
them and verify all of them okay so
that's a really big concept beyond which
most people understand
and you can understand that okay if
that's the case then
a house can go on a blockchain yes
because the deeds and then you don't
need a notary and then you don't need
lawyers there's all of this stuff
most legal stuff can actually go on this
and then the breakthrough is that okay
we've got another thing that's going on
in digital world which needs solving so
this contract thing is a big deal we
don't even know what this means yet
right when we talk in 10 years time
we'll go oh my god we didn't see that
coming right so that's all happening and
defy is that there's contractual
obligations between borrowers and
lenders it's all happening on chain
but what the
the average person is seeing is a
different breakthrough that came out of
this whole concept
is in digital world everything that gets
digitized goes to zero in value
or cost
everything
right the price of data the price of
everything is zero over time
so that's a big problem
if you're
living in an increasingly digital world
so how do you cement digital value
is you have to introduce a system of
scarcity
and an nft allows a digital asset to
have scarcity
okay
breakthrough
now it could have come from the music
industry it could have come from a
number of different places it ended up
being the art market
okay
and where you can say
this stuff that was now was basically
worthless online
i mean getty had bought a bunch of image
rights but to police it is really bloody
hard as well
so okay now we can create a one of one
of value or a number and do that so that
becomes the value of an nft the next
part of an nft
that you say okay well if we give a
bunch of people these
we can now identify a community
and then these people can be like-minded
communities because they coalesce around
an idea which is this piece of art and
this community which is bulldape yacht
club or crypto punks so that becomes an
incredibly value it's a membership to a
club
and it's your identification it's
showing your rolex and you know it's all
of that
stupid identifying tribal stuff that
humans do endlessly and always have and
always will so that's going on and it
allows us don't forget the
internet had taken us from our towns
villages families which is our social
structure
and thrown us into a big shouting room
from people all around the world with
different views right
it's quite exhausting
and we all wanted
a place
and what this is giving us
is these little digital communities
sovereign states villages towns cities
where we can now operate with
civically minded people within that and
these tokens are the identifiers social
tokens are the big thing they're they're
not com they've only just started that's
much bigger i think than even nfts are
but let's start with this because this
is a way of coalescing humans because
humans like these kind of identification
system of shared values that kind of
stuff
so nfts are a lot of things
that's why they're so big
and
again that's just scratching the surface
of what this is it it can also and will
also be your digital identity online
right you said something about music and
i saw you tweeting about music and kind
of the future of music royalties or like
how anybody can become an a r you know
uh person now
describe what you kind of what you're
thinking there because i think that'll
be fascinating to a lot of people
because music is one of the music like
art is a great entry point for a lot of
people whereas you know macro investing
is
deeper in correct so what is the world's
most vibrant communities
it's sports and it's culture
that's fashion brands
fashion brands more than any others
it's music
it's art it's these things right culture
the big unlock here
is if you can tokenize communities
which is now the network owner is the
same as the network user remember that
facebook example right so now we've got
pop star
and token holder
they're all now joined in the same
network
so now every incentivized to grow the
value of that network you've now made
culture and investment
this was not possible
you could take a cultural marker like an
adidas sneaker
but you weren't making money from
adolescents you had to buy the shares
and there was no connection between the
consumers there was no network of adidas
users
now
you're about to create networks amongst
these people so what is the value of
lvmh the fashion company right with all
of its kind of mega brands that people
are passionate about that are status
symbols that humans like we've just
talked about love these things so the
same with music right we're all tribal
in music we love different music we like
different bands so to be part of that
network i could now be a
16 year old kid and never have to have a
job because i happen to get involved in
the right i'm good at finding the next
pop star
well if i buy their social tokens
or i invest in their song ip on nfts
right
i'm in business so what this is creating
is a system i think is universal basic
equity
where culture is the investment they're
not living in your world where they're
building businesses and having to sell
them and go through the entrepreneurs
miserable journey um they don't have to
do that
they do a different way
which is by using their
human instincts about the communities
they want to be part of and which
networks are going to thrive
and music is so powerful because it's
human emotion um and people and it's
it's a place in time i remember i'm a
huge music fan and you know i identify
music by its year what i was doing what
it smelled like what i heard who i was
hanging out with i mean everything right
music is is one of those anchoring
things so
just the ability for musicians to now
sell directly and have a direct
relationship with their fans via social
tokens and nfts
is literally a game changer i mean there
is no way on earth snoop dogg would have
been able to sell something in small
numbers
and make 50 million dollars
it's just not that big a star
because record labels
um because 80 of all the economics of
selling music gets taken by middlemen so
he'd have to sell a huge sum to do that
or he'd have to go on tour and to make
50 million dollars that's a big
exhausting tour you know he's no spring
chicken anymore these things are you
know it the music industry economics got
destroyed by middlemen and it made the
artist have to work harder take more
risk with capital which is like have to
go to massive tour i have to rent arenas
and take these trucks
this changes all of that dynamic and the
metaverse changed it one stage further
yeah like the artist had to create uh
scarcity uh which was basically come to
my concert there's only x tickets and
that's how you can see me and then they
also created status which was take
photos of yourself at this concert post
that online and that's a big part of the
value that you're gonna get out of uh
out of coming to this thing and then now
we have a digital version of that which
is and and so when all these people
spoke to each other the fans they'd have
to go on a facebook group and facebook
monetizes them
right right and if they want to go on
tour they need to go on facebook and
google and pay everybody
but when you've got
millions of token holders you've sold
out 50 of your tour you've de-risked
everything in minutes it's just it it
stops you having to use middlemen all
the time
and uh you talked about two different
things there's like the sort of like
almost like the
thousand true fans uh you know concept
where basically an artist can drop
something that's rare and exclusive or
access to them or their commit their fan
club and the it gives the whales you
know something to go by that they would
you know that they're they're actually
willing to buy more than just a t-shirt
uh now you give them something worth
buying and so that's that's one thing
that you could do with it but the other
one is what's talking about buying a
stream
a part of the royalty right the part of
the royalty stream and so that's where
you know
i remember i don't know i
i remember finding macklemore the the
artist when he had like you know
whatever 2000 fans and i was like this
guy's great and like if i had actually
been able to bet that this guy's great
and therefore be a part of his community
he views me as a backer and true
believer and i did i remember i
kind of did a kickstarter with him or
whatever he he pre-sold his album and i
just gave him you know 30 bucks because
yeah go use this to help make your album
pay for some studio time
but he didn't know me i didn't have a
relationship but i had nothing to show
for being right and
and so now in this in a world like this
where the 16 year old kid can say i
think these guys are going to be great
their price is cheap right now and i
could buy you know some of their future
um
there's even more magic
because that 16 year old kid because
he's now financially incentivized to
grow the network and make that song a
success it doesn't make sense like 100
tick tock videos yeah exactly
right and if you multiply that by all of
the
token holders of those ip rights
they're all marketing free for you
because they get paid in the upside it's
genius
i mean think about it like uh
you know if you doubt what you just said
just think about
who's bitcoin's cmo
who's
who's the chief marketing officer there
what's their ad budget and then how much
publicity do they get who's their pr
person how much publicity do they get
how much chatter how much you know the
ticker that's sitting on cnbc all day
showing the bitcoin price right like all
of this happened because you had a
network of people incentivized to go
shout to the world how great this thing
is um you know and and people hate that
about crypto oh there's just people
shilling their thing
yes and that does get annoying and you
know you have to filter you know signal
from noise but at the same time you have
to appreciate what that does it turns
everything every believer into uh
every society is the same
so if we think of everything is the same
so let's assume bitcoin is a social
token ethereum's a social token let's
assume the us dollar's a social token
and let's assume that
religion
is a
social status token essentially
so
everybody goes the same way to increase
the value of that thing so the us is
like we've got military might and we're
the greatest nation this is the free
place and everybody can become a
president right that's their narrative
right every country has a different
narrative to drive its value system for
its network because they all require
incoming capital to support the network
including the church which couldn't have
survived without incoming capital so
they get all these people out to go and
tell the word of god they then spread
the dish around take money in it builds
the church it grows the network they're
all the same that's humorous the book
sapiens kind of goes through this a lot
about how
humans need to self-organize
yes
well said i think that's that's a
perfect zoom out uh we can kind of even
even pause or stop there so uh
where should people so follow you on
twitter your role gmi uh you
also have real vision and people should
go sign up for that i mean look if
people are interested in crypto really
easy i've set up an entire free crypto
um channel which is realvisioncrypto.com
it's all the great and the good of the
entire industry everybody every week i
interview like who i think are the
people i really want to pick the brains
of and i go down all these journeys of
social tokens and music and macro and
all of this stuff so there's so much
there and it's free real
visioncrypto.com
awesome all right thank you for coming
on i appreciate it i really enjoyed it
thank you
[Music]
you